パパ分久しぶりに付いたよもっともっと笑って
さっほー
だっはぁはぁっ
カッコイッこんにちははじめ社長ですね様皆さん好きですか
僕も大好きでスペアんだよお肉禁止してるんですけど
が薬を突いてまずは食べてますえっ子がネットの記事で見たんですけどもうこのペ
アームと一時期ネットでも話題になってたこのストロングゼロと述べてるかねすごいね
なんか
ドラッグ的な言い方をするみたいな弱さが出てましてアルコール9%って強いんです
けど飲みやすいですよねこうなんかジュースみたいな感じで
周南市でべろんべろん4つみたいで海外だとこんなにかかったにをいるのがないみたい
でなんか外国の人からするとメグ外国から日本に来た人はもうストロングゼロ買い
まくってるはホヤべくレジーナやばいこれ木場れて来ませんでどんどん決めて来らしい
です
ん
お酒は二十歳になってからですよお酒をすすめるために動画を撮ってるわけじゃないん
ですけどもうこのエラーメール側ニート60ぶっかけてくると
なんかすごいみたいな記事を見たのでやってみようと思います常に僕はこれ1本飲むと
ベロンベロンになりますバイサイド僕で撮った時にもうめちゃくちゃになってああ
ああああああ
バッハ voodoo
美味しいなにすごいをいるからやっぱりさすがというか美味しいです
まず水便で作ってきますかやくはこのお肉の塊があるのでキャベツだけちょっとずつ
入れていますちっちゃのニックスの僕に打てないんで可能な限りキャベツだけ
ピックアップして焼くとも作っていきます
ok をざっくりとホントこんな感じですおやかーこマウスにチャンネル待ちますあの
どのタイミングでストロングゼロを入れるかと言いますと普通に完成させてから
ぶっかけるらしいそれではネットで見たやつだったあの普通どちらのペアんぐに
ちっちゃい管の音60入れてるんで僕もて街などで買うのですからね最強レベルだ
あっハイツあの人かゲージ載せとくんですけどめっちゃみんな美味しそうに食べてるん
ですよなんかでも実に美味しそうなんだなぁいいなぁいいな
[音楽]
削除しましたおいぽい車これまでないから丁寧に切りましたぁー
うますお詫びマシンあの惨事ですたら今日でもうこの動画のために何も食わないように
してきたんでめっちゃ減ってます
そして明日朝9時からです
助けてくださいまあもうそれも関連語で僕になりますからねまず普通にソースをかけて
ペヤングを作りますうっうっしー取りにくいテラーシンプルにこの文句言いたいが企画
ならず三度かけていきます
ちょっとずつちょっといい子でていただきます
馬いやほんとねリンクがなくても美味しい
で待って本そ都営でも美味しいのと薄いのをさせばおいしくなるって方程式があると
思うんで
でも大丈夫だと思いますなぁみんな今日も一日お疲れ店
考え
エバーって本当にこれ大丈夫だろこれ
ねしばしば言ってるんですけど出っ張ってや待って待って待って待ってちょっと食べて
みて嬉しかったラコットかけますねー
水気がヤバイ見た目はそんなに変わらないなぁミスちゃっちゃ
いただきますどんな子なんだろまったく想像を使う
[音楽]
えっ
あっはぁ
うまいぞまあ
甘いこれで美味いなにこれえっ
あっはアの最初の主人乳が凄いんですけど
7でも役所みたいになってますそれそっか今でもう際て目指して
[音楽]
なんか変だ変な味だな勢いよくすると絶対なんか国になっちゃうよ
またこれ
良いそうだななお風ちゃんの役者もならずは残っていますこれで甘くないからさー甘く
ないでもなんでね側と魁都没哲ちゃんのレモン風味よう何度の高
唐揚げにかけるようなレモン汁をちゃんと来たしてるみたいな感じですよくわかんない
よね氏ねでも
[音楽]
ソドーがすごいうめーなーは麺が
ラックスボットは違うあのシコシコしてきてですよねええいいね水 is 式で oc
ねやっぱもうやばいもう頭がグラグラしてきたすげー
北へ来そうだ銘板バンガーハァハァいや楠北って俺酔ってるよぺちゃくちゃおいしし
食べやすいんですけど
ん
良いますねこれもう地蔵なバーでだいやほんとすごい
あのペア雲おいしいとロングでも美味しい
そしてよっちゃ
全てがそう思ったまるで悪魔のようだ
焼きそばでしたはい
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ